[Music]
in soulmate instrument news Oh for the
flute of my heart submitted by why is
josh not on JK news that's a long story
Duda would love to had Josh as he would
not make any sense a violin prodigy he
we mortgage her home to buy a five
hundred and eighty thousand dollar
violin but it got stolen and she fell
into depression five hundred thousand
dollars back at length
is it one of those called a like a
Stradivarius or something
those things are hella over the ones
that are made for like a tree in the
cold area right or something for back in
the day and it's like made them like the
1700s or some [ __ ] and you can never
have a known or 1600 s why is it a brand
name in there the man I was constructing
I create these violins his name of
Stradivari there's only a limited amount
that's why he only created a thousand
but they're saying about 650 have
survived I may feel like it was like
very more like a weird point of like
weather right yeah exactly they're
saying like scientifically like since
then we haven't seen the same type of
weather repeat itself so he created
these violins out of the wood in that
extreme cold which made the wood really
dense that's a very specific sound Wow
somebody stole it I just pictured him in
the cold
[ __ ] trembling and then he's like
this [ __ ] violin craftsman and he's
creating this [ __ ] and then he's broke
as [ __ ] and then but he's still cold and
he's like making it he's like one day
one day I'm gonna make these the best
violins in the world many people start
buying it and then one day you know
Beethoven's homies get it and then he
starts to become the talk of the town of
the classical music and then he becomes
famous dude they don't even know we're
mother duck duck goose
dude one-of-a-kind originals coming out
yep $500,000 t-shirts made in the oldest
office you cannot duplicate it with a CS
63 the
AC is so cold and we're gonna be
trembling who loves the violin so much
that they would pay $600,000 for it this
girl so this is coming she is not up a
Chinese variety she's going on people
that value classical music though yes
so people that plan those I still
harmonics whatever those are the people
that have a Stradivarius violinists when
they rock out they really lose
themselves like I've never seen any
musician lose themselves the way that
violinist do is like a full body and
then the whole time like you know how
you're in this [ __ ] position like
this so they're just and then they have
this looking cheek that's all the way
pressed and closing their eyes at the
same time they love it though do it hey
[ __ ] you love it dude it's crazy do you
know what's so funny
when a Jason Chen plays a violin he's so
small looking in the guitar to say me
show me show me
Jason cheddar looked like this we should
this is my kids by 11 so tiny it's
[ __ ] cute with this Oh Jason you
[ __ ] cute [ __ ]
yes so this story is about min champ 31
years old
she's a violinist and she was a child
prodigy when she was seven years old she
was accepted into this really
prestigious school so violin is life
exactly my life why in his life yeah and
then four years later she won the
prestigious international Mozart
competition I like how there's
prestigious in the title you guys should
do that the prestigious powerlifting
meet the prestigious California Southern
California Marvell Brigade powerlifting
me you have to do your list with the
[ __ ] monocle in your eyes yeah and a
top hat BAM yeah so this is
[Music]
turn on first rad yams walk she spent
how much five hundred and eighty
thousand dollars that's a high you know
why she actually got got it for a steal
the original worst like the actual worth
of this violin is 1.2 million dollars
how did she get half off and that she's
Korean dude that's Allah dude knows how
to bargain
please [ __ ] the scratches on their own
she had been playing on this island for
like at least a decade and one day she
was at the sandwich shop at this one
train station in the UK it's the UK
that's why that was a syndrome I bet she
was from southern Korea no she's Korean
but she could agents don't have the
street smarts because in Asia they are
not specifically Korea Japan they don't
have like people Stephen from them all
day long so they can leave [ __ ] around
she has grown up in the UK then she just
never family went over to the UK once
they discovered that she had this like
intense talent international hard town
there is absolutely no way I would carry
something that's worth 1.2 million
dollars and not have that [ __ ] is
surgically attached to my dick she did
have it insured that your [ __ ] I'll
come to you now the traditional
handcuffed to the head and then the
handcuffs to the case maybe like I said
she's not street smart he was asked
before her specific Stradivarius is from
1696 way easy do so when she bought it
it was like in a really bad condition
she had to restore it when a ton of
money and each year she has to spend a
couple thousand on just maintaining it
the lustre got to put like the oils in
it is [ __ ] okay yeah so anyway she was
at the train station with her
then-boyfriend
and what a shitty boyfriend let her [ __ ]
get stolen apparently wasn't stolen
under the table like between their legs
didn't even realize that she's saying
that she was so devastated with the loss
of this instrument because at this point
like that instrument had become a part
of her she said like that was her soul
it was like no other instrument can
replace that
all people should have be Stephen
actually these don't usually go for
violins it's an inside job on the
meetings because it's the UK so they're
classy thieves I think they know what
she's expensive like they're stealing
art pieces violins to go in the museum
stone statues but more specifically and
it just seems to be a case so they
probably knew what was inside it you
probably saw the case go to the the
shine of various they need special cases
that keeps a certain humidity level to
like a cigar yeah and they're part of
like holy [ __ ] that's that case so it's
the violin and it must be hell I don't
mean to be a dick but I just look like a
normal violin to me
I know mobile bars like I don't know I
don't know nothing I don't know anything
but I just know people that have no
regard with their life yeah not to the
girl well I mean the value in the violin
is because it had like gold plates on it
you know this is just the wood I don't
think like most people when they see a
violin they're like that's a Stradivari
I want to make one correction now I did
miss state how much it was worth I said
1.2 million dollars that's in pounds in
the USL is 1.5 million that's a luxury
home and you spend like eight hundred
thousand USD on this one no I was
actually four hundred and fifty thousand
pounds but five hundred and eighty
thousand US dollars and then that's not
even including all the work she put into
it to get it to it yeah exactly
unless you have to keep paying draw
everywhere to maintain it I feel worse
but article goes on and on I just feel
like my heart to tear well let me give
you a little bit of happiness so three
years after it got stolen she got a
phone call or a text actually two guys
take I got serious from the
investigators here and that they let her
know that they found her Stradivarius
what was good they can't say how they
found found it because it's a part of
another investigation of other stolen
things oh they went undercover and in
the cop seduced the robber she cried her
eyes out this Thomas Crown for those
three years she was in severe depression
like she can't even get out of bed she
said like it was always on her mind like
she couldn't play and he wasn't people
it is
oh I didn't mention this but she was
actually like a like a really
world-renowned violin violin oh that's
what I'm assuming it has one the only
people I don't have them are [ __ ]
crazy yeah I crazy I guess it wouldn't
be the same I think I'd pick up another
violin and go it would frustrate me do I
just like picture heard you like waking
up in a bit alone I'll look at having
night tremors in check he hit one note
Kyoto gave it a chance at one can you
imagine her mom like just Julia you know
I know it's not to say I just try one
time please give it a you mind you mean
all you might like it
after the violent was recovered since
the insurance that she got on it they
did pay out the money doesn't even
matter to her though yeah cuz that Pilar
is one of a kind but apparently the way
they're reporting because I don't know
the details but the way the report is
that she was eventually like forced to
give up the violin to an investor so I'm
not sure tubulin yeah so in the end she
still didn't even get to keep her
beloved ontology poor guy that's the
thing I don't know the details dude just
give her back her [ __ ] violin though
she's gonna die yeah she owned this her
heart
what's that investor going to do anyway
with that violin that person is probably
just gonna like keep it in the home
display case can't even play that [ __ ] a
lot of them make money off of it so they
own it and then they'll put it in
museums or they'll loan it to people
that play in the Philharmonic and they
get charged and they rent them out
they're so expensive
you'll get it back to her man molest it
like that just be saying this about her
Stradivarius and other instruments like
it quotes they don't earn their keep in
the concert hall they earn their keep in
the dark which is bad this is going to
be a bunch of other DC as Asians crying
there's no one else understand
oh you know what they'll say that I want
to have a passion in life as strong as
her passion for violin because that is
the difference between somebody who is
good and somebody who was exceptional
that is what Iowa I don't know what the
hell she did also mention that her
family like they beat her into it
exactly it was so like yeah they were
pretty much beat her into because she
was saying that there would be time to
she was a little girl that she was just
like you know I just felt like a diamond
being pulled out to be shined every time
I'm tired of it like I don't want to be
performing Toofer whenever you guys want
me to perform but like she loves it but
she was also forced into it but if it
wasn't for that El Tigre type of parent
okay good she would have been an
excellent yeah she is right now so
there's a double-edged sword because it
actually turned out they nurtured
something that allowed her to be great
what there's a given thing and she has
an unhealthy attachment to an object now
because she identifies herself with the
violin exactly yeah a lot of people are
commenting talented as Asian kid all in
the comics that don't know Asians they
go oh my god you see this is the thing
with Asians they're so disciplined and
they have so much work ethic and all
this stuff and I'm thinking you don't
know that these kids are getting their
asses [ __ ] beat every single day and
they hit this [ __ ] when you see a
talented little white girl you're like
oh dude this is this is pure fun right
they're not getting their ass beat every
day maybe a Russian gymnast maybe you
know but then when I see these Asian
kids like doing anything talented at
four years old I'm like that kid gets
beat every [ __ ] day I feel so sad
except at Dance Moms that's mom's Dance
Moms are the only ones gymnasts Moss the
white the white dad's mom oh they're
just embarrassing like Katy Perry stage
moms hope you guys enjoyed that video
but if you didn't guess what you can
directly contribute to the articles that
we discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up
you
[Music]